we can calculate the depth d of snow in
centimeters that accumulates in harper's
yard during the first h hours of a
snowstorm using the equation d is equal
to five times h so d is the depth of
snow in centimeters h is time that
elapses in hours
how many hours does it take for one
centimeter of snow to accumulate in
harper's yard pause this video and see
if you can figure that out
all right so we want to figure out what
h gives us a d of one centimeter
remember d is measured in centimeters so
we really just need to solve the
equation
one centimeter when d is equal to one
what is h going to be and to solve for h
we just need to divide both sides by
five
so you divide both sides by five the
coefficient on the h and you are left
with h
is equal to one-fifth and the unit for h
is hours
one-fifth of an hour so one-fifth
of an hour if they had minutes to there
then you would say well one-fifth of an
hour they're 60 minutes we'll use 12
minutes but they just want it as a as
a number of hours so one-fifth of an
hour
how many centimeters of snow accumulate
in per hour or this is a little bit of a
typo how many centimeters of snow
accumulate in
in we could say one hour
in one hour or they could have said how
many centimeters of snow accumulate per
hour that's another way of thinking
about it so we could get rid of per hour
so pause the video and see if you can
figure that out
well there's a couple of ways to think
about it perhaps the easiest one is to
say well what is d when h is equal to
one
and so we could just say
d when h is equal to one when only one
hour has elapsed well it's going to be
five times one which is equal to five
and our units for d are in centimeters
so 5 centimeters let's do another
example
betty's bakery calculates the total
price d in dollars for c cupcakes using
the equation d is equal to 2 c
what does 2 mean in this situation so
pause this video and see if you can
answer this question
so remember d is in dollars for c
cupcakes now one way to think about it
is what happens if we take d is equal to
two times c
what happens if we divide both sides by
c you have d
over c
is equal to two and so what would be the
units right over here
well we have dollars d dollars over c
cupcakes so this would be two
dollars
because that's the units for d per
cupcake
dollars per cupcake
this is the unit rate per cupcake how
much do you have to pay per cupcake so
which of these choices match up to that
the bakery charges two dollars for each
cupcake yeah two dollars per cupcake
that looks right
the bakery sells two cupcakes for a
dollar no that would be two cupcakes per
dollar not two dollars per cupcake
the bakery sells two types of cupcakes
no no we're definitely not talking about
two types of cupcakes they're just
talking about cupcakes generally i guess
i guess they're one type of cupcake we
don't know but just cupcakes generally
is two dollars per cupcake